puis nous avions été informés des
risques mais vous savez j'ai toujours
pensé que la france est en guerre
le risque était permanent et je regrette
d'ailleurs que pendant cette campagne on
est si peu parlé des questions de
terrorisme et des questions de sécurité
comme si après les massacres du bataclan
de nice la france était entre
parenthèses non et c'est justement
s'imposer désormais jusqu'à la fin de la
campagne je le souhaite je souhaite
qu'il s'impose parce que la france est
en danger les français sont en danger
car les mesures n'ont pas été prises et
c'est pas nouveau d'ailleurs et les
projets sont très différents entre mon
projet et les mesures que j'ai
énormément travaillé sur la sécurité
ceux de certains je crois qu'il ya une
grande différence
et justement je demande aux français de
lire les projets avec attention car ce
ne sera pas la même chose d'être
gouverné avec les mesures que je propose
est avec les autres